hello and welcome to crash course cries
fear I'm Tom and I'm Simon and this week
I'm gonna be looking at mass balance
this is how ice is lost and gained from
ice sheets to graces we're going to be
looking at energy budgets and ready to
transfer something that's much more
important than what Tom's talking about
[Music]
we've examined how water becomes ice and
now we need to look at how a glacier is
born a glacier is defined as a body of
ice that flows downhill under its own
weight therefore there are two
requirements for glazy to form firstly
enough snow and ice must survive the
summer melt season for there to be an
ice mass present from year to year
secondly there must be enough mass of
ice for it to deform and flow under its
own weight
this concept of flow is very important
to show how important it is we actually
refer to ice that is no longer flowing
that once flowed as dead ice it's no
longer part of a glacier it is no longer
flowing and therefore it is dead ice ice
flows are complex and fascinating
business that we would explore in detail
later first of all we must look at how a
glacier is maintained so we need to
understand how glacier ice Falls glacier
ice that's very different to the ice you
might have in your freezer at home
greater ice is this deep blue color and
this is because it absorbs non blue
wavelengths much more readily due to the
lack of bubbles within it sorry to
interrupt Simon here just to say that
this mechanism for why glacial ice
appears blue is actually really really
cool but we didn't have time to talk
about it in a series so if you'd like to
learn more about it I've left a link in
the description sorry to button Tom now
wants to talk about how glaciers grow
with each year's snowfall as the annual
layers of snow accumulate the ones on
the bottom will start to become glacial
ice we're going to try and demonstrate
this for you now using this perspex cube
our soapy snow a bit of water and this
water bottle what I'm first going to
take here is the winter snow you can see
here that it has quite large flakes so
I'm going to add this now as our first
layer
here we get okay we're gonna do it from
the front I think
yeah very good this is our first layer
of snow okay so that's our first winter
layer of snow in now I'm going to add
this summer layer we have much smaller
flakes expertly carved by Simon they're
smaller
partly because you're generally speaking
get smaller snowflakes during summer so
it's less chance to grow and also
because that's generally represents the
final ice crystal structure a bit better
it's now I'm going to add this summer
accumulation layer okay it's very much
finer so it takes a bit more to get a
good layering smells lovely by the way
lemon and citrus now what I'm going to
do I'm going to add just a little bit of
water in this water is to simulate
melting and refreezing hopefully this
should percolate down into the winter
layer somewhat and that's a similar
effect as to what you see in the real
world just a little bit of water just to
wet the top of the summer layer and now
I'm going to apply a little bit of
compression using this water bottle this
is to simulate the weight of the stuff
on top and the compression taking place
hopefully what we should start to see is
the top layer it can press quite firmly
and the bottom layer is starting to seal
up the particles of the winter layer are
not fully bound together again where
they're starting to do so thanks to the
water input from the summer and the
pressure from the other layers above I
was going to keep doing this now and
hopefully you should start to see the
pattern evolve whereby the bottom layers
can get more and more compressed as
compared to the top layers so here we go
[Music]
okay so now I'm just adding the last
winter layering as time has magically
fast-forwarded running a bit low and
hopefully you can see the platen that
has emerged between these winter and
summer accumulation layers now this is
something that if you ever end up
studying ice cores or look at ice cores
a tool is very useful of course this
means you have a perfect record when
each year was can simply count the
layers that you see in your eye scores
and therefore counts how many years have
passed
this means that ice cores a very good
way of measuring the climate if you can
establish an absolute date for one of
the layers and then count back from that
well I don't think that went too badly
and hopefully you can see the different
layers that we have here tom is of
course exactly right that ice cores are
a valuable source of data on past
climate but how do you get those ice
cores in practice it's time to take a
trip to the archives so you see those
accumulation layers if they're in a
perfect cube but in real life we need
something a little bit more involved and
we have Korra's we have two small
examples here what are you well so you
go out on the ice and you want to be
able to investigate what's going on
underneath the layers you need to be
able to collect it somehow now on the
piece of it it's not really obvious how
that might work with these but like many
things designed for youth out in the
field and yeah I do have hidden secret
so that part I mean I just thought you
can see there we've got a nice groove to
put your icing so there are two pieces
here this bit I'm not going to put it
all together but you can see that slots
in there nicely and and it just clips in
place and there's a drill bit on the end
you can twist them exactly and then once
you've done that you've got your little
groove so then you can take a slice of
it
slight serrated edge right on the end
there that you can just about make out
so that you can get this purchase on
your ice so you just pop it in then
you've got a little column of ice you
can
the idea is then here you can see the
accumulation mode as you go down through
this is a very small example it is yes
so how big do these things get they get
very big so typically something like the
British Antarctic Survey have a big
store with these icicles and they can be
that much in diameter so what's that
about hundred million diameter and there
were these huge drilling rigs so they
might go down by a kilometer they're
going get these things out and then of
course they have to store it and quite
often they'll take slices and I look at
the guest pockets that are in the slices
and analyze so there's a lot of analysis
there's a lot to determine from it
because we have a time series aren't
they yes deeper you carry the further
back in time yes it's a bit like tree
rings yes yes so you're getting lots of
layers and each layer has qualities
related to the time that that smokes
hell yeah in a nutshell that's it so
you've got something candy that you can
just pop in your rucksack or on your
sledge your start time you're traveling
or your schedule and fairly lightweight
it's probably a kilo there and thinks
it's quite a big lump of metal and can
go and do your little bit of collecting
so with something like this P probably
wouldn't be storing it to take it away
you just be collecting it and doing an
analysis there yeah I'm a bit more basic
than with the really big cause but these
are rugged instruments India designed to
take a beating in the field this isn't
some precious laboratory thing but you
know the slightest knock will destroy it
what the polar regions if you want to go
and work in the polar regions you first
will have to get to the place which is
by definition remote so everything that
you take with you has to be able to
withstand the travel and the experience
you're going to put it through just
getting to these really difficult places
to reach and if you lose them they're
very brightly colored that is true very
important only I haven't seen it with
these but quite often you see pictures
of skis stuck in the snow and a reason
for that is because if you need your
skiing for six so you can find them so
it has to be something similar happen
videos as well we'll be back in the
archives next week now we're going back
to Tom who's talking about how fluffy
freshly fallen snow turns into hard
dense glacial ice
mechanisms that increase ice density are
moving by the wind changes in the size
and shape of the crystals themselves
changing the internal structure and
movement between the ice crystals these
processes are greatly accelerated by the
melting and refreezing of water on the
surface of the glacier an interesting
thing to note here is that pure ice has
a density of 917 kilos per meters cubed
at 4 degrees Celsius which is where we
pick with it water changes its density
with temperature at 4 degrees Celsius
water has a density of a thousand
kilograms per meters cubed this is a
strange property of water and is one of
the fundamental reasons why ice floats
so on we'll take a look at this physics
of this in a future episode but glaciers
don't grow forever we've just been
talking about accumulation here and if
just kept accumulating then eventually
that ice would reach into space which
clearly doesn't happen so somehow the
glacier is losing its mass one of the
concepts that helps us understand this
is that of energy budget the energy
budget of the glacier now unfortunately
this means we're now going to have to
talk some physics and so here comes
Simon okay so we've got energy but what
does that mean and how does it move
energy can be defined as the ability to
do work pretty general right well that's
because energy can come in lots of
different forms like netic potential
even nuclear but when it comes to
physics this is the key definition and
the key thing when it comes to energy is
what's called the first law of
thermodynamics which sounds scary but
honestly it's not all it means is that
energy can't be created or destroyed
only changed from one form to another an
example of this would be for example
somebody bungee jumping they stand on
the top of a cliff where they have a lot
of gravitational potential energy then
jump off gaining a lot of kinetic energy
then the bungee cord will expand and
stretch and stretch slow them down and
convert their kinetic energy into
elastic potential energy a note point is
energy in this process been created or
destroyed it's just changed from one
form into another
and into another the earth as a planet
experiences lots of these changes of
forms of energy all the time and all the
energy that's coming into the earth
apart from a small amount which comes
from geothermal heating from the Earth's
core
comes from the Sun in the form of
radiation
now radiation isn't what you're thinking
probably radiation isn't what you might
be thinking of as nuclear radiation
which are alpha particles and beats
particles and gamma rays that are
emitted by nuclei undergoing certain
reactions what we're talking about here
is radiation in a general physical sense
which is the transmission of energy
through a medium so between the Earth
and Sun there's no air there's no water
to transmit energy it's just a vacuum
but that doesn't matter to radiation
because radiation arrives in discrete
packets or chunks of energy which we
call photons these photons travel all
the way from the Sun to the earth and
are absorbed providing all the energy
input to the earth energy budget an
example energy budget would be that
radiation arrives from the Sun providing
our input and then some of that
radiation might be reflected by for
example snow so it gets pushed back out
into space but some of it would be
absorbed now some of that absorption
might take place in snow for example
which would then raise its temperature
by increasing its thermal energy and it
might be enough to melt that snow
changing it to water which can then flow
out of the system carrying thermal
energy with it so we have input from the
Sun a process happening and then an
output from the system this kind of
surface energy budget and others like it
are absolutely key to understanding how
ice evolves we can understand how
glaciers gain and lose ice by pitching
is a very simple system a system with
inputs such as the accumulation that
we've already discussed internal
processes the subjects of many future
episodes and outputs this gives us the
mass of the system and the mass of a
glacier is fundamentally controlled by
its energy budget and therefore we have
what we call the mass balance mass
balance refers to the change in the
amount of ice in iglasia over a
specified time period mass balance is
divided as two components the
accumulation and the ablation
accumulation is the input of ice into
the system and ablation is the removal
of ice for the system accumulation can
include things like snowfall as we've
already demonstrated there are also
other processes such as avalanches down
onto the glacier of the surface from the
surrounding mountains accumulation rates
can vary greatly depending on the local
circumstances or my favorite examples of
really incredibly quickly queuing
rates is the Patagonian ice fields down
in South America
here you have warm wet wind coming in
off the Pacific and hitting the
mountains very quickly and therefore you
get huge rates of accumulation as much
as 14 meters per year in contrast so
this year the Antarctic Dry Valleys
where accumulation rates have measured
in fractions of a millimeter snow is
typically the most significant input
however you can get other inputs via
super cooling of wind carried water
which produces rime ice or via the
upwelling and ponding of water onto the
surface that then freezes and then
becomes part of the glacier itself now
both of these processes supercooling a
particular of relatively small
contributors but because super cooling
is so fun we're going to do a
demonstration of it anyway super cooling
is the process where a liquid is cooled
below its freezing point but it doesn't
become a solid due to a lack of
nucleation centers now water which is
very pure and handled very gingerly can
be supercooled in lab conditions which
is what we're going to try and do in an
experiment for you well when tom says
that we are going to do this experiment
what he means is that he is going to do
the actually fun bit I have to do the
set up what I have in front of me is our
experiments in constituent form so talk
you through we have a bunch of regular
old table salt we have two lovely jugs
here full of ice which is actually the
most place you're going to see in this
whole series and a perspective key with
these two bottles of water now this
isn't just any old water this is very
very pure water which is deionized water
that we bought the supermarket this
one's been dyed blue but you'll see why
in a little bit now the way this
experiment works is we need to get these
down to really cool very cold
temperatures so first of all I'm gonna
put a whole bunch of ice in this cube
I think that mostly within that so as of
the moment these bottles are now getting
going to be getting quite cool but
they're not going to be getting cold
enough to properly freeze or they get to
freezing temperature because remember
we're trying to supercool these we don't
want them to actually freeze into ice
just yet so we need to help this along a
little bit which is why we have the salt
so remember that in episode 1 we talked
about the fact that when substances
undergo a phase change for example from
solid to liquid or from liquid to solid
there's an Associated latent heat a
certain energy that is required to go
undergo that transition which is to do
with changing the molecular bonds in
ices case when ice melts it goes from a
crystalline structure to a more
incoherent liquid structure where there
are less bonds between each individual
molecule we are interested in trying to
unlock the power of that that phase
transition and we're going to do that
using our salt so salty water has a much
lower freezing point than fresh water so
if I add a whole bunch of salt to this
ice as I'm doing this I'm lowering the
freezing point of the ice in this
perspex box what that means then is that
it is apparently oh look at all that go
this ice is currently solid when it's
temperature it indicate that it
shouldn't be so it's currently more
walking taste salt on a map currently
more thermodynamically stable for the
icing here to be liquid than it is to be
solid so it's undergoing to undergo a
phase transition to water doing that
however requires oh so much so during
that however requires energy from
somewhere it needs energy to break apart
the crystalline bonds the hydrogen bonds
between its molecules and it's got to
find that energy from somewhere so what
it does is it takes energy from its
surroundings and its surroundings in
this case means a bottle of water so it
robs a whole bunch of thermal energy
from the bottles and doing that lowers
the temperature of them and if we're
lucky we'll get these down to about
minus 8 degrees Celsius so what I'm now
going to do is leave this 13
and let's Tom come and do the actually
really cool part of this experiment with
you Thank You Simon for that always good
to have a helping pair of hands now in
what we showed you just now we actually
forgot to add the water on top we did
that straight afterwards unfortunately
what we don't have here is a thermometer
in order to measure to minus-8 our
budget doesn't go quite as far as the
BBC whom provides us the inspiration of
this experiment what should happen is
I'm going to put out the blue bottle and
then I'm going to put some ice cubes in
here and while I'm through the ice cubes
first pour the blue bottle on top or
we're sure we should see happen is that
the water will freeze on contact with
the ice cubes and then freeze back up
into the bottle that's the idea let's
see if it happens
the second thing I will do is then
slowly remove the white bottle hopefully
it hasn't been disturbed too much and I
will wrap it on the table and hopefully
we should see that from the point of
disturbance I the bottom of the bottle
the water will freeze from the bottom up
okay moment of truth my heart is
genuinely beating quite fast right now
let's see what happens
got the lid off that's a start
nope that's not cold enough after that
surface I think sticking your finger in
it it is very cold but clearly not cold
enough now a possible reason that didn't
work because we add a blue food dye
which may have modified it slightly will
give the white bottle ago now and let's
see what happens this is science by the
way so much during the course of my PhD
and I'm sure that during silence as well
you try something it doesn't work so you
have to keep on trying and trying again
until you find something that does
yes freezing we have freezing we have
freezing there's a bit of freezing at
the top there ah here we go yeah it's
needs a bit more agitation there we go
yep done you can see this on the closed
camera now but the core of that water is
now frozen ah sort of success and now we
need to remove glacier mass from the
system this is done via ablation
ablation is quite simply the removal of
ice from the system and this can be done
through a variety of means the main one
of these is just pure melt but you can
also have wind scour iceberg carving
into water or dry carving which is
simply the avalanche of ice off the
front of the glacier melt rates can be
calculated if the energy flux of all
sources is known this relates back to
what we were talking about earlier with
Simon this is usually expressed in terms
of surface lowering of course not all
melt takes place on the surface and
radiation can penetrate into the ice and
cause internal melting this creates
planes of refrozen water as the ice
melts in the Sun and then freezes again
at night along ice crystal boundaries
the key points in this episode are that
in order for ice to become a glacier it
must exist in a layer thick enough to
survive the summer melt season and thick
enough to flow processes to occur that
the mass balance of a glacier is the
accumulation such as snowfall - the
ablation such as melt that with a lack
of appropriate nucleation centers a
liquid can be super cooled below it's
freezing point without becoming a solid
and that a way to understand how much
melting or ablation will take place at a
given point in a glacier is to consider
the energy budget at that point
thank you for watching crash course
cryosphere if you'd like to take your
understanding of the subject covered in
this episode further there are links
down there in the description and if you
have questions about the material
covered then Tom and I will be in the
comments for the next two hours
after this is uploaded we'd like to
thank all of these lovely people up here
who helped make this series possible and
in particular the recover project at
Exeter University for helping fund this
and
Scott Polar Research Institute for
housing us and being so accommodating
we'll see you next week for more icy
action
you